you guys are going to hate this one but
we could turn our 2D friend into their
Mirror Image by rotating their entire
body around a line for a brief period
halfway through most of their body was
missing from their 2D world except for
the vertical line around which they were
being rotated a four-dimensional
creature could turn us into our Mirror
Image by rotating Us in the fourth
dimension around a plane that cuts
through our body for a brief period
halfway through our rotation most of our
body would be missing from the third
dimension except for the vertical slice
around which we were being rotated now
would be quite a frightening sight for
anyone here to witness